foreign
foreign
you're back with the three hosts the
three Muslims
how y'all doing this
how are you guys doing
damn bro you're my God you gotta lower
your mic or something yeah you gotta
lower the game bro oh man damn you gonna
make us
my bathroom I was not
is that better a little better
everyone's always telling me do uh to
raise my my mic volume so we got 117
viewers right now in the
in the Stream may Allah bless you all
for tuning in
um yeah before we uh go right into it
you guys saw the thumbnail you guys know
the main question that was commonly
asked so I'm gonna put it right here I
don't know if you want to address that
foreign
I literally unmuted myself and then you
re-muted me
now I can't hear y'all a young muted
I'll mute yourselves so I can hear you
speak
come on I need to hear something I need
I need to see if my audio thing is
working okay okay yeah it's working bro
uh
uh fired are you single
Rami are you single no alhamdulillah I'm
married
alhamdulillah this answers the question
then let's move on
[Laughter]
a man's avoiding so hard I know bro
all right
guys alive right now
I don't know bro
that's an interesting question all right
let's go next we are pushing from
smoking
marinara how do I prevent getting sucked
into life's Temptations as in early 20s
female
that is tough
that is tough where do you go
I don't know hold on one second hold on
one sec
um
I mean it depends on what the
Temptations are you know early life
Temptations are you talking about the
temptation of wanting to fit in and uh
perhaps you know stepping and doing
things that majority people are doing
that you should not be doing well in
that case you should just either
surround yourself with good people good
company that's going to encourage you to
do good and stay on the straight path or
just be by yourself and just don't be
around the the people who are going to
persuade you to you know basically
be worse in life I would also say
getting married to a good Pious man is a
good way to avoid the Temptations
and just you know stick to
the Quran doesn't keep Allah on the
Forefront of your mind
um
the thing throws the sink
oh no bro you got another follower
what you were saying bro
well some someone wrote we know y'all
are married
[Music]
are married
why can you not say you married well
because
I never said that I was it wasn't to be
honest at no point
my man's trying to game the audience bro
keep them on their toes
uh let's see
now actually you know what I'll just say
because there's no point in like just
fighting it off or anything I just I
like keeping my life private unless you
guys haven't really seen that you know
yes I share things here on the three
Muslims and my channel
but I maybe keep some things private but
I guess I'll show you so
good enough
yeah that's that's pretty much it
physically not uh but yes
bro I want this on record bro all three
of us no more questions no more marriage
questions bro
let's see
oh
no no but I did pray Estacada
and it wasn't
actually yeah probably before meeting
this person and then I placed harder
when I met the person just to ensure
that this was uh the proper one because
let's bro let's let's ask this next
question bro this is a really good
question I've never thought about that
uh you want to read it out because some
people are on Spotify
what would you guys do if one of you
guys left Islam like what would what
would we do like like let's say raw me
let the same stuck for a lot it's not
even think about that let's let's say
Rami did leave like are you asking what
would me and fire do or what would we do
like if we were the ones that left Islam
no no what the former
the former how you know
because I understood it as like oh what
would I do if I lived Islam
if one of your guys not you yourself
left Islam otherwise I would say what
would your guys do if you left Islam
um
I'd be pretty sad to be honest man yeah
the dynamic wouldn't be the same bro
yeah
bro it ain't gonna be the same yeah
no I'm playing bro Rama you're not
replaceable come on
everyone just implies everyone wasn't
replaceable like that
yeah
replaceable yes but would it be the same
no of course not of course not it's not
very good there's not an exact replica
of me fired or on hell um anyone's
replaceable right like imagine putting
like you know
um uh
or someone on here bro that like in
terms of knowledge that'd be way way
more significant to have him on right as
a as a host but it's not me it's just
not going to be me
um but what would I do I would just keep
giving doubt it would hurt me obviously
you know it would break my heart but I'd
keep giving dollar to that person and
live my life and go on and
Islam would go on and Dao would go on
and T3 mashallah would go on it's just
um that's just life
oh fudge was funny bro he wrote the he
wrote the thing about my own events yeah
listen I had to I had to close that down
actually like once I got married you
know I had to have some uh
[Music]
these ladies in the streets you know
but I see my only my only fans was uh it
was the only men
sign up oh Brothers only yeah brother
uh yo Rami Rami you're real serious bro
you like don't worry bro I'm not gonna
let anyone know that you were the uh the
first person to sign up
I would appreciate if you don't let
everyone know that I was the first one
to sign up he just left he just let
people yeah we just we just got we both
just let them know but it's okay I got
the premium subscription I got the heist
here and I actually got it on two
different accounts to show my support
um
that's why I'm so serious I'm reading
some of these comments yeah guys you
spend the if you send the Super Chat
we're gonna guarantee uh answer because
the way stream Yard Works it comes up at
the top
um otherwise normal comments I'm just
gonna kind of go through them one by one
so we got two super chats I'm just gonna
go through them first one's from Brother
Dominic
um I'm trying to reconcile these ideas
of determinism and the Free Will in
Instagram that these things have been
written by the will of Allah but we sin
so actually we mentioned the live stream
for us the Hobby and um he actually gave
a very beautiful answer
to this whole dilemma and it was from a
more secular perspective but it is kind
of the Islamic
um narrative as well so when it comes to
determinism and free will they are not
contradictory
um because if you look at determinism as
encompassing your free will then you can
still have both you're your ability to
choose is already encompassed in the
chain of events that are going to happen
there is only one chain of events that
will occur and that is set in stone and
within those chain of events that are
set in stone it encompasses our Free
Will and our ability to choose so just
think about it like this Allah has the
ultimate will no one's will overseeds or
supersedes Allah's Allah by virtue of
his own will gave us the ability to
choose
by the will of himself
so
Allah writing in a book
before anything was created exactly what
will happen
is not determining what will happen but
it's writing in a book what he knows we
will choose to do and as soon as you say
something like if Allah knows what I'm
going to do
how is it free will you've already kind
of failed because you said in your own
statement
if Allah knows what I am going to do
you didn't say if Allah is making me do
it because we know naturally Allah is
not making us do anything we know and
there's something within us that just
knows I have free will
I'm choosing to do what I do
and the idea of determinism on an
individualistic pers like level or
perspective if anything is just trying
to push away the
um the responsibility you have to be a
good person
I know it just came back like Smosh yeah
bro you look like a Smurfs
what's going on with that bro why he's
gone too bro oh we hurt his feelings man
I don't know someone will finally got
the podcast love mashallah to around me
for the very succinct answer
um it's you know to reiterate it's not
that Allah makes you do these things
Allah just knows what you're gonna do
you still did it therefore we're still
going to be held accountable for
everything we do but Allah just knew it
because Allah is Unbound by the
limitations of a human being you know
such as you know not knowing the chain
of events Before Time occurs
next question slave of God rights and
you know thank you for the Super Chat
how how's brother Zach Gonzalez is he
fine do you all hear from him uh was he
authentic in his story yeah so um from
what we know again
um he was authentic from a story we did
talk to him lately he's just been going
through you know a lot of things in his
life in his personal private life
um he did mention it's okay if I share
these things you know with the podcast
so alhamdulillah recently you know he
did get married too everything's kind of
going good
um but you know there's a lot of things
he's taken care of right now so he
hasn't been you know in front of people
um there were times after he made that
video with us that you know things got a
little dangerous and because of that you
have to kind of watch his back for a bit
um but alhamdulillah is fine keeping it
to us
I'm gonna
and sister marriage is alcohol okay for
the Super Chat next on her bro any beer
tips
after that we talked about this so much
man I feel like this information can be
found almost everywhere like I feel like
every live q a has like the same four
answers and people just keep yeah
yeah it's cool though um so first off
you gotta know where your beard is it's
like is it is it like very little is it
stubble is it kind of short is it kind
of like long
um depending on that you have to you
don't know whether to grow it or if you
have to like do something else to it is
it thick is it full if it's not then you
either have to wait and let your
genetics play the course or you can use
Rogaine and the Derma roller
um I don't know from personal experience
the effectiveness of this but I have
heard that people have had great success
with this and unlike the head hit when
you use Rogaine on your head if you stop
using Rogaine you lose all this hair but
with the Rogaine on the beard when you
stop using it you actually keep the hair
on your face that grows from the Rogaine
and the Derma rolling so that's a way to
get it more thicker and to fill in in
the spots that maybe it's just not
filling in for you
and uh mashallah
on those beard more mashallah
yeah
quick Super Chat from Brother Hamza 50
pounds exactly Fair no question Brothers
may Allah bless you all for spreading
the truth of the Deen I mean and helping
us in our Journeys highly recommend for
all Zombie podcast and his channel
how do we ask for uh her Baba's number
without it being weird
it's always going to be weird bro
that's all I'm gonna say it's always
going to be weird
yeah no way around it
I think the way to make listen the
weight it's only weird if she's not
interested in you if I'm being
completely honest
if she's not interested in you you're
gonna go ask for her father's number and
ask for the hand in marriage if it's
weird it's either because her dad is
weird and he's not open like that and
that's his fault or she's not into you
and that's just no one's fault she just
doesn't like you move on but if you if
you get to know her if you talk to her
you get to know her and you like her and
it's clear she likes you and you go to
her and say can I get your father's
number she's not gonna just like freak
out she will either say yes or she will
say listen my dad's not really like that
he's not really into it and you guys
have to push to get the father's number
anyways because you have to go through
him or some kind of money maybe start
with the brothers
that's a good way to put it that's a
good way to put it I was thinking too
like it's usually us who make it weird
like in our heads we think like it's
more weirder than it actually is so
that's why I'm saying like it's always
going to feel weird because like
you're about to ask this girl like hey
let me can I get you for this number so
that I can ask him for your hand in
moods like even if you've kind of
already been talking with the girl for a
little bit it's in your head it's gonna
feel weird but I like what you said
where it's like if the woman makes it
out to be an issue well then she just
she doesn't have like she's not
interested or there's just something
going on there with the family
yeah 100 in this box bro we always we
always just
think of ourselves in a very overly
critical way we think we're weird we
think we hate our voice and like all
these things it's weird
no I agree bro
someone wrote uh where the other wrote
can we ask questions to them yeah so you
can ask questions
to anyone bro yeah anytime you want to
ask questions to someone in life just
ask them I'll never go I don't want me
to cut you off bro no bro it's all good
brother face out bro I can't read those
too far I think I'm saying the name
right how can I be protected from fitna
without being married
I'm only 16.
um
he gave the advice to get married and if
he said if you can't then fast so to
follow the advice Department which is
always the best advice fast
um there are other things you can do on
top of fasting regularly which I think
Angel's gonna get into inshallah because
he's probably better better suited to
answer this because he talks about it a
lot why don't you take it over bro
oh no bro you you said it perfectly
though like the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam like whatever he says that
should be always first
and um what I said before you said it so
my bad for uh not thinking before I
speak but that would be purpose
purpose because like yes you have to do
the fasting but if one only fast and one
just disregards
like purpose and them having purpose and
then the next thing would be like
self-improvement if one disregards that
too like you're just gonna stay in the
same place so you're gonna keep fasting
but then the moment you stop passing
well all right that's it are you going
back
100 we must stay focused my brothers
must stay focused
also things like working out you said
self-improvement which encompasses all
the things I'm gonna mention but you
know basically working out learning
things developing Hobbies working on
your hobbies your goals a business
whatever you know all these things trust
me all these things will keep you away
from uh from LA Fitness inshallah
um
young Houdini shout out to you you just
became a member
let's see
Mars writes what if the girl has four
brothers you just do it bro it's nothing
to be intimidated on come on now
yeah bro it ain't that big of a deal
we just start trying to martial arts
though
that's all I'm gonna say
um
brother rights where do you see your
channel in five years Insha'Allah
helping more and more people that's it
oh this is nice
King wheel writes advice to increase the
love for a prophet saws
that's a beautiful question may Allah
bless you and if you think about it if I
were to ask who do you love the most
it's probably the closest person to you
who you know the most about
you know you can't come and say I I love
Rami I love him I love Rami Angel and
fayad and you know nothing about us if
you don't know us you don't love us so
if you want to love somebody the prophet
peace upon him get to know him if you
got to know the prophet who he was what
his life was like the things he did his
sacrifices
everything he went through
you will love him just listen to the
Sarah read the Sera and even if you know
it refresh yourself on it even hearing
or reading the story again
will just bring that love again for the
prophet peace and blessing be upon them
I don't know
that's
um that's Superman's name bro
that is um I think it's otigo's name or
something like that
but it's actually I might be getting it
wrong but Cal L like that's his name and
I know that because my friend is like
really into Superman so he told me that
yeah I bet bro my brother Ali writes
advice for praying Fajr consistently and
waking up for it do you find a disrupt
your sleep cycle so I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you guys right off the rip that if
you're looking at you know a medical
point of view let me just kind of move
this aside if you're looking for a
medical point of view testosterone point
of view scientific point of view right
that's always going to say you know you
need continuous sleep you need x amount
of sleep you know but I'm telling you
this too when it comes to an Islamic
point of view you know Islam transcends
a lot of these things and limitations
through like empirical science and all
that type of stuff waking up for fudger
regardless of if it interrupts your
sleep or not meaning that you don't get
all of your sleep before pleasure you
have to pick up
what you do it's still gonna change your
life waking up for fudger specifically
if you can go to the Masjid Game Changer
bro game changer starting your day right
bro there's literally days where I wake
up with the alarm I don't feel like
going up or getting up but I still get
up anyway and then I pray Fajr and then
you know when I wake up later even if I
go back to sleep I don't regret it I've
never regretted it in my life so I think
it's definitely something you just gotta
do some things in life yes there are
practical steps that I can give I'm sure
the brothers might have a different
answer other things in life let's do it
there's no like perfect way or or a way
to kind of make it easier you just gotta
do it
yeah and I have an example I I want to
pray the hajjud one of these nights I'm
sure everyone has had probably like an
example like this but you know when like
you say you want to do something and um
you know whether you ask Allah or not
like it may be intention and like maybe
you you wake up just out of nowhere you
might wake up before your alarm clock or
something like that well that's Allah
like like a lot like I haven't gotten
sleep in the past few nights so I know
I'm exhausted but I would love to pray
to hajjud and now as you know I just
sincerely asked you know if
if I if I can do it then allow me to do
this you know and he woke me up he woke
me up at like two or three A.M
and that was definitely not after the um
the Sleep Cycle had finished when I
looked at the time and all that stuff it
was during the sleep cycle and the
amount of energy awareness and just
focus that I had upon waking up and just
going into making me do and then going
for the prayer it was more than what I
would have had if I would have gotten
like that perfect perfect sleep schedule
on point where it's like I got right
there on the Sleep Cycle I woke up and
nah bro it's like if I had said man like
it these things when it comes to Allah
like it transcends bro all the things
for us like is this
is this
is how it is for it this is not even bro
this is nothing like it's even smaller
than what I can even put right here
just think about that it's even smaller
to Allah to Allah like what we
experience and our problems always
nothing but like this is nothing to
about
hmm
grab me anything on that bro and all
those facts 100 subhanallah and um a lot
of the time it helps just put in that
perspective just think like think about
your problems from any any case it's
like
Allah can literally do anything in the
world
anything
Allah could cause
a billion dollars to fall out of a plane
through your roof into your lap and not
harm you
and no one even knows it landed in your
house somehow like Allah could do
whatever he was
um so obviously making sure you wake up
at a certain time so Allah but at the
same time that doesn't mean Allah will
right so easiest way easiest way
sleep on time if you can't sleep on time
because you're staying up all night if
even if you can't wake up for Fajr make
sure you wake up at some point early in
the morning
9 A.M 8 A.M even 10 a.m stay up all day
live life be a normal human being go out
see people work out go to school go to
work whatever you'll be tired enough
when you get home at a good time to fall
asleep you fall asleep at 10 pm 11 p.m
get a you know five to eight hours of
sleep you wake up at uh Allah that's a
beautiful Point bro and just to add to
that for anyone that wants to fix your
sleep cycle it's highly recommended that
you do what brother Romy said where you
set the alarm early one day right even
if you're not used to it but you like
for example let's say you're waking up
at like a noon every single day you know
degenerate sleep schedule I've been
through it the brothers have been
through it we've all been through it but
let's say this is you right now you're
waking up at like 12 or one or two right
set it early like brother Romney said
one day like eight or nine something
like that and when you do wake up right
get a lot of sunlight in from your early
hours of the day the more sunlight and
even artificial light you get starting
earlier in the day the more melatonin
which is the hormone that makes you
sleep the more of that hormone you
suppress so
to keep it in a very Layman friendly way
you know the more melatonin you suppress
earlier in the day so the more light you
get earlier in the day the more sleepy
you get as soon as the sun sets so
people that are up early when the Sun
rises they're like out and about you
know getting Sun getting even light in
the room you know the more they get
there from early on and if they eat a
meal then as soon as the sun sets
shortly after by the time it's like Isha
bro you're going to be ready to knock
out so that's like the best way I
recommend to fix a sleep schedule the
second best way is just pull an
all-nighter and go back go to sleep
early the next day but I don't really
recommend this because you're going to
be in sleep debt the next day and the
next day you might catch yourself you
know you know waking up even later than
noon or whatever
alhamdulillah
to move for the super shot
brother Vision Chaser writes the Andrew
tape podcast was amazing Bros martial
love for taking initiative and being
leaders tomorrow is my 25th birthday and
the best gift I got is Iman mashallah
mostly thanks to you guys alhamdulillah
by the way who here uh has a taste from
Mechanicals and speed think about cars
adrenaline
I like adrenaline
yeah that's classified as speed yeah
I've never been a car guy but I've
always loved cars if that makes sense
hmm yeah I got you got you yeah me too
bro
extra life rights what is the main goal
of this channel when we started this
channel we had the the goal or intention
of just helping one person come closer
to Allah and that's literally been Our
intention till that day since that day
this was in December of 2020 so
basically like very beginning of 2021
you'd say that's when we really started
this channel that's when we launched
everything and this was literally our
goal
alhamdulillah
um
that's uh that's a good question that is
a really good question I I'm a person
especially like
in in the past I used to get especially
with people close to me I used to get
hurt but her are really stupid things
really dumb things and um
my best advice is if you can't draw the
line just try your best not to be
offended
at anything just try your absolute best
um if you have boundaries as a human
being
then don't let people overstep those
boundaries for sure
um but if you just have to be realistic
like imagine if someone asked you to not
do whatever it is you're asking them to
do like let's say you get offended when
people eat in front of you imagine never
being able to eat in front of like your
your loved one it's like you definitely
have the problem you're making their
life so much more inconvenient for
something that
very few people or no one else asks of
other people but if you're if you're you
know boundary is I don't want you
talking to Ops the opposite gender
that's that's the Islamic Norm
I think that's a good thing I should
compare it to what Islam says about
whatever you're asking about I think
that's a good way to to determine what
do you guys so uh I got a good example
here all right so
in one hand you have being offended like
genuinely being offended on the other
hand you have being overly sensitive
right or just sensitive in general
if someone tells you something and then
you begin to get emotional and your
emotions begin to control you and what
you say and how you act to this person
and and this whole situation that's you
being sensitive
but if you are offended then instead of
the emotion taking over it's more so you
being assertive and speaking up and
saying what you have to do in order to
be uh very did I did I say it for me
from from to be very firm right because
like if something offends you you want
to say exactly where it is and you want
to stop that right there in this CH in
in this case or in this track so I
should say
um you'll get the picture I'll get the
picture
there's nothing I can even say to top
that bro that's honestly what it is and
you know I want to give a huge shout out
to my brother anho who uh showed me the
perfect example of what it means to
never take any ish from anyone and
always know his worth so mashallah bro
talking about Iceland
I'm talking about in general bro know
your worthy baby girl
for being a member and sending a Super
Chat and Allah bless you uh she writes I
don't want marriage and kids but my mom
keeps telling me that I will regret the
23 but marriage is not for me
don't say that don't don't say that I
think that's
yeah I'll let you go as well like me I I
think I remember hearing that before I
think I remember the process I'm saying
don't say I will not get married but but
but don't call me on that might be
confused so don't quote me on that but
definitely it's from the Sun not to get
married the process I believe he said
that that Nika is from my Sunnah right
so you're going against the son of the
Prophet by saying marriage is not for me
now there's reasons you're saying
marriage is not for you you're a sister
I can I know why you're saying marriage
is not for you because you don't think
there's any suitable guy that can
contribute to your life out there I
don't want to go into personal detail so
I won't
there is there is a man out there who is
good good for you good in his religion
good in his character and will
contribute to your life in a beneficial
way he will financially provide for you
at least to some extent and that will
make you feel more woman womanly and it
will make him feel more manly and
Charlotte there will be a good Dynamic
there so I'm not saying go and run off
and get married all I'm saying is 23 is
not it's not too old right but do not
shut it out make do I pray and if
someone comes to you
don't shut him out just because he's a
guy please for the for the love of God
it'll save you you don't want to be 50
and all your friends are married and
you're not married and you're sitting
alone in your house
you don't want that I see that a lot bro
there's a lot of these sisters nowadays
they kind of unfortunately fell for a
lot of this uh modern women's movements
you know even saying the word Savannah
will get this D platform now and get a
strike but they fall for a lot of this
stuff and the programming that goes with
it and at the end of the day I'm not
here to say you know women can't study
your work or whatnot it's not a place to
say that but what I will say is it's in
both of our fitras as men and women
naturally the way Allah has made us to
Crave intimacy family marriage this type
of stuff so understand that if if
there's something within you that
doesn't want that why is that it could
be perhaps some type of uh experience in
your childhood that has kind of
triggered you or grown up and and kind
of having a bad example of marriage
around you so you've Associated marriage
with those bad examples even though
those you know Case by case experiences
that you've witnessed so it could be a
lot of different things but on home what
do you think before we go on I think you
also the perfectly honestly okay
alhamdulillah next question
we got from a main
everyone is worried about their pea size
before getting married but nobody talks
about the level of testosterone so
what's the least amount of you uh least
amount of you uh least amount you should
have I think that's what it means before
getting married uh bro I would say
anywhere from like 600 to 700 nanograms
per deciliter I know today the average
amount they're going to say is obviously
from like you know anywhere from 300 to
like a thousand and they're gonna say oh
if you're at 300 that's okay I
personally don't again this is not
medical advice or anything like that but
I think 300 is pathetic the average like
60 year old about like 56 years ago has
the same testosterone as like you know
probably like anyone our age now I think
that's disrespectful bro
hi baby bro let's just keep it simple
for them man
if you wake up and you're uh your
soldier down there is saluting you
you're good
if you wake up and uh he's hey he he's
still sleeping
and that's like a constant thing all
right then you should probably start
changing up your lifestyle you know
eating better sleeping better doing more
exercise moving more stuff like that
um there's ways you can improve your
testosterone inshallah reach out to
either me or brother on her links in the
description you know we got you
inshallah
um next question brother Raheem writes
what is the line between being oh no
nevermind we already got that we read
that bro you move that next we got a
question from Brother Mo how should I
balance going to the gym studying and
working just turned 20 today what age
did you get married or own place
studying molecular cell biology
mashallah I saw Allah
what you think agave
I feel like any of us can answer this
question because all of us have to
balance a lot in life right yeah
um kind of do it yeah go ahead go ahead
all I want to say is you just kind of do
it like you just you you set the most
important thing at number one which the
gem is definitely important it's never
going to be the most important thing
right
um for example your prayer your Salah
your your family your your work probably
the most important things in your life
or school for your in your case School
most important things in your life
um you fit the gym maybe in between
classes you have half an hour an hour
you just you just end up doing it you
know what I mean on him bro what do you
think
I agree on that point to add on to it I
would say first you just do it you start
doing everything and you try to find the
balance and then second is like knowing
exactly which one has the highest
priority because you could be working
but you could have some time during your
work to actually study maybe studying is
like your main priority you know what
I'm saying uh there's more that I could
say before it is there anything you
would add
um honestly just have a schedule bro
I use uh I use this app called calendly
and it's linked like you know you can
link it to your Google calendar or iOS
calendar or anything like that and
anything I have from like my coaching
clients I put on that anything I have
one on hold on me wants to do something
off camera I put on that anytime I go to
the gym bro I literally put it on that
because if I don't then someone has my
County link like a client and they book
it then I can't go to the gym at that
time right so I literally use calendly
for anything and everything that I do
this is not a promotion you know we're
not sponsored by them just like brother
Angel was promoting a lot of Lactaid
pills in the in person we're not a
sponsor for that you know but we do give
credit words or it's due bro definitely
so do you do you schedule your bathroom
breaks
only sometimes bro only like the long
ones you know yeah I'm doing that I'd
say
the last scene that I would add on to
the the point to bring it all together
is to not waste time on your phone like
Social Media stuff like that because
that that'll be the worst thing it's
like you know you have these things to
do but it's so much that you just you
end up not doing you go on your phone
and you spend hours like just looking at
random stuff like this is not this is
never gonna allow you to find a balance
on her real one I think they're
referring to your uh your comments yeah
the soldiers Soldier
yes we are we
I don't wanna should I should I get I
think I think you've I think you've been
pretty eloquent enough bro and if they
don't understand that then I don't even
know what to say bro
someone wrote it always salutes me with
kindness
Muhammad
we can't we can't say a lot of different
terms bro otherwise we're gonna get you
know yeah yeah
I understand Sharif writes Andrew Zucker
for the Super Chat do you guys use sauna
uh massage machine and stretch
yo voila I just read that
as um do you guys use the sauna and
massage gun on like I'm not gonna say
what I've read in my mind but I'll say
the translation which is the soldier
like I was saying in the other thing
I thought he was asking we was a sauna
and a massage gun on our soldiers I was
like whoa bro if you want to put him
damn jealous I was stuck for a lot I um
I I should stretch I think about it
often I never do um and I I don't use
them I don't even own a massage gun to
be honest I think it would
probably relieve a lot of pain a lot of
pain yeah I do yoga
yeah
bro I still do it because like it the
flexibility and Mobility that I get from
it is amazing it just gets really weird
sometimes I'm not gonna lie like
sometimes it's just really weird or
being like in this weird position I'm
like yo if I were to see myself doing
this like back then
I'll be so disgusted at myself
all right guys leave uh we got about 15
minutes left please leave a Super Chat
down below if you want to guarantee our
response we got about five Super Shots
that we're gonna blast through
Insha'Allah
um next one is from the same sister uh
sister Khadija who wrote uh basically
you know I don't want to get married I
don't want to do this I'm 23 my mom
wants me to get married she writes now
by the way I am a feminist and entitled
LOL I have a childhood you know I can't
say that word because again you you guys
have no idea what words get get strikes
on YouTube it's it's kind of insane but
whatever uh childhood bad experiences
and I don't know how to cook and clean
so I'm saving myself from divorce I know
marriage is Sunnah
um seems like you're you're kind of you
have a fear of things not working out in
your favor so you're kind of like let me
not go through it and possibly get
burned let me just not go through it at
all
um it's kind of a nihilistic way to look
at it but what do you guys think yeah
yeah 100 actually the first thing that
came to my mind is it's it's an
ideological or in terms of your arcade
that there's there's a a deficiency
there and that's obviously no like just
back to you it's just you know if you're
looking at it not from the perspective
of I'm gonna do my best and Trust in
Allah you're looking at it and from like
Fires at analysis perspective which is
like it might not work out it's great
I'm just not going to get involved to
begin with that's a very
that's that's I honestly I think that's
very sad and listen it as an individual
you'll probably feel a lot better
and wait time out there is no way you
don't know how to clean that's a lie
there is no one on Earth that doesn't
know how to clean yeah anyone knows how
to clean that's not true you can clean
cook is different cooking is like an art
you can learn how to cook sister
your mom wants you to get married go say
mama teach me how to cook she'll she'll
love it bro she will love to sit down
with you inshallah and teach you how to
cook you know how to cook you know how
to clean because there's no way you
don't don't tell me you don't you do
drop the feminism uh I just got his
demonetized
no no don't worry don't worry
we'll drop the uh
the uh yeah
don't let me reach through this camera
and slap you bro drop the feminism
please
and if you feel you're entitled please
drop that as well
go back to the basics of the Quran and
the Sunnah learn how to be a good wife
and if a good husband comes your way go
through inshallah go for it and listen
even if you end up in divorce in the
future may Allah protect you from that
and our sisters and our brothers
if it happens it happens there's nothing
you could do to control it Allah just do
everything you can to prevent it in your
own head
foreign
um but uh
actually I'm gonna try to hold back I
don't wanna I don't want this to come up
the wrong way so uh may Allah make me
have the best of speech here for you but
it sounds like you're playing the victim
card
and I don't say that in a way to like
put you down I say that in a way to like
show you
that hey you know if you were to not do
this if you would have not play the
victim card look at what you could do
look at what Romney just said you could
ask your own mom
just show me how to cook and she would
love to show you how to cook
right you you think that a man is not
going to do anything for you you pray to
Allah you pray to Allah you ask Allah to
put a man that is going to do something
for you ask Allah to put a man that's
actually going to change all this way of
thinking that you have right now
and if you think that Allah won't do
that then
I don't know what to tell you but it's
like we were saying before
our problems are nothing to Allah you
know like if you if you think about it
we always speak in all of existence like
think of us as a human and then think
about the universe that Allah created
look how small we are in this creation
of Allah
right and then you have Allah Allah is
bigger than all of his creation
so if you think if we're a splick
in comparison to the the the universe
and if we're we're less than a spec in
comparison to Allah we're nothing in
comparison to Allah then what are your
problems like you really think that
Allah can't just change things like that
for you you know so it's like and Allah
says very clearly in the Quran
indeed he will not change the situation
of a person until they change what's
within themselves so you have to make
the intention you got to put that victim
card down and start to see okay how can
I do this differently how can I do that
differently you have to be willing you
have to make that first step
and uh yeah look at you who started on
her bro mashallah I love that answer bro
no no no no don't don't please go I
ain't no stud now listen bro I'm just
saying martial article I just see how
far you've come in the last two years of
being a Muslim may Allah increase you
and keep yourself ass on the dean bro I
mean and those such a good answer bro I
don't even know what to add to that
um brother Danny writes uh you are
straight L why are you even here saying
you are uh um you know the reality is no
man would want your whatever stay safe
bro can I can I address this around me
don't don't read it you can adjust his
comment don't I'm not going to read it
bro listen I'm not saying the words stay
single and shut up no one okay bro I
sure as hell hope your ass ain't Muslim
bro there's no way you could be a Muslim
and hear you know be racist bro there's
no way that would not make any sense
whatsoever in the Quran Allah
specifically writes then Arab is not
better than a non-arab non-orub is not
better than Arab whites are not better
than blacks black abandonment white so I
don't I don't get why that comment came
Additionally you know I see a lot of
comments too that are attacking her and
I want to make it clear too I see a lot
of brothers that are kind of following
you know red pill and you know they're
kind of extremely anti you know these
types of women and I think it's a very
reactionary thing it's not coming from a
place of groundedness and I see a lot of
these sisters too unfortunately they're
coming from a reactionated place to
specific types of men and if y'all keep
coming from this reactionary point of
view you're never gonna get to a point
where you are going to understand one
another the way Allah has you know given
us the free will the compassion and
empathy to understand one another and
I'm not seeing this to Danny because I
support this sister's movement that's
not what I'm doing I don't support that
whatsoever I'm anti that but what I do
follow is Islam and Sam tells us to have
compassion and teach one another to
understand one another not to just be
reactionary for example if I see a
sister at this extreme I'm not going to
come to her from this extreme from like
red pill or anything like like that
because that's going to be too much bro
it's going to drive her further away
what I will do is meet her where she is
at and then try to understand and make
her understand why what she's following
is not correct and what a better
approach will be and I'll leave that by
example and through character not
through harsh words bro you're not going
to influence anyone like that
bro
I mean like we're in Uma we're a
community like you're supposed to look
out for one another
whether it's a brother or a sister like
we are all part of the same like
religion we're all brothers and sisters
in Islam and you already know like
Muslims were not perfect no human is
perfect
so we have to be very
aware man very compassionate you know
like we have to understand that okay
this person's imperfect they might be
doing something that we might not agree
with and all we can do
is remind them all we can do is give
them nasiha and if they don't want to
follow the okay to call us and leave it
with that but like I don't know the the
comment wasn't needed I would say that a
comment wasn't me messed up that that is
your Muslim sister like ideally as a
Muslim man
you should be willing to die for her yes
if she as an individual and you as an
individual or in the street and you saw
a Man attacking her you should be ready
to die for her that is your
Duty as a Madness now that is your duty
as a man Islam you should be willing to
sign up for it but what are you doing
you're sitting here and you're
bad-mouthing her and you're
disrespecting her and being racist and
going against the son of the Prophet
peace be upon him and what Allah
commands Us in the Quran and it's
disgusting
she's wrong 100 percent
we don't we don't support that at all
femininity we don't support it
but why bringing racism into it maybe I
just got to demonetize everybody just
say bro just say just say empowerment
screw the terms man screw the terms but
bringing that into it what are you
achieving honestly what are you
achieving stop for the lava thing I put
them in timeout bad boy bad boy you're
in timeout but what you did think about
what you did uh
that's Fox bro
because unfortunately I do I do see a
lot of this in the ummah and this is not
the The Deen that the prophet saws came
bled for put his life on the line for
this is not the Deen where we're racist
and were were discriminating one another
for the color of your skin bro what type
of what type of you know nonsense is
that bro I understand that in in
specific you know white supremacy
movements what type of stuff is that in
Islam bro you think there's a place for
that in Islam
and and it makes no sense bro and check
yourself bro it doesn't matter if you're
you're someone hating on just black
people check yourself if you're hating
on anyone for anything that's
unwarranted and unjustifiable and I see
this a lot in a lot of different
communities I'm not gonna mention any
names now because my experiences might
be anecdotal and I don't want to
generalize based on those experiences
but I've been to a lot of different
countries
where Islam is supposed to be the norm
there and I have experienced a lot of
hatred and discrimination because I'm
not from that type of appearance I'm not
from the type of culture and that's not
okay bro we're all ambassadors of Islam
so that's not how we should be
if you want to read that out one of you
yeah I got it inshallah uh says
let not the Believers take these
Believers for friends and preference to
Believers tips for and then he says he
quotes and then he asks tips for finding
strong Muslim brothers who want to
relentlessly build and improve all I
have is YouTube depends on where you
live I'll say go to the Masjid is the
first place if you're in school go to
the MSA
um in anywhere where there will be
Muslims who inshallah are practicing if
you don't have that unfortunately you do
have to you know meet people online and
be friends with them online which is not
ideal but it's better than being alone
and
um give that one maybe you will convert
people to Islam and bring them to Islam
and once they get to a good level of
practicing you know you'll be mutually
beneficial for each other
but for now I think focusing on yourself
is the most important thing
yes there are yes sir that was that was
amazing I don't know anything you want
to say for that
you you already started
to do it for yourself but get deeper
into it for yourself and you'll notice
that you'll start attracting that or not
even uh let's let's leave that that
weird New Age terminology stuff away uh
you'll start to see that Allah starts to
bring that into your life because Allah
loves consistency and when Allah sees it
you're consistent in learning more and
you want this this is what you want in
your life you want also other people who
are also learning more and trying to get
closer to Allah he will put that in your
life
mm-hmm
all right next we got let me see
Romney I want to hear a take on this
because we gotta wrap this up soon so we
got some Super Shots off this too uh
Rahman writes I think
fem is fine if you only advocate for
women's rights prescribed in Islam since
some Muslim communities do not fairly
fulfill these rights especially
um
that
South Asia
so let me reconstruct what you're saying
because Muslims don't practice Islam
properly we need to bring an outside
ideology that white men created decades
ago to basically liberate but actually
constrict Muslims and strip them of
their practices in order to bring back
Islam and what Islam says in terms of
the rights of women
you see the problem you're not bringing
Islam back you're bringing another
ideology that is Progressive that morphs
into something else and that eventually
actually in both ends in the beginning
and what it becomes is on Islamic it is
a man-made secular ideology
that has morphed into making women into
men and men into women
right there have been six maybe seven
waves of feminism maybe in the first
wave with voting and all that stuff okay
stem was already on that 1400 years ago
okay no thank you it was already on that
no need for it now it's morphed into
something that is is ruining ruining yes
it is ruining men and women so why would
you want such a thing why don't we just
teach our Muslim Brothers what Islam
actually says about women rights teach
them to be Honorable Men to honor their
women to take care of them to be modest
to be chased to be all the beautiful
things we ask men and women to be and
then we will have a non-promiscuous
proper Society if anything the problems
you are seeing are problems that
feminism brings because now you are
expected to work and provide 50 of the
income when Islam gives you the right to
be taken care of in your basic needs
necessity
so it's a double-edged sword you will
lose every single time so forget that
feminism and come to Islam inshallah
yeah and you got to think about it too
uh before we even read how do you just
come here
this is an ideology
as humans we attach ourselves to
ideologies right the moment we attach
ourselves to an ideology we start
learning about it like the more we learn
about it the more attached we become and
at some point or another
this this the this movement this
ideology here that we're talking about
and maybe in the very beginning it was
somewhat aligned with Islam but at some
point it completely veered off course
just like red pill completely veered off
course like all this stuff may start
with the Slime but then it veers off the
path all right and
at that point once it views off then you
have to go through the cognitive
dissonance of letting that go so that
you can come back to Islam and that's
very difficult so why not just start
with the slam from the beginning I want
to just start with this ideology and
it's not even it's more than ideology
but we'll say for the example purpose
start with this ideology attach yourself
to that and then you'll notice that at
no point do you ever have to let it go
because it's complete
I'm not following that ideology it's
chicken against the dean
um I can't conform nor then either
because I'm not a scholar but um you
know for the sole purpose I can say it's
definitely on Islamic
um I was just joking thank you all for
the advice and love
may Allah bless you just in the future
don't don't say don't even make jokes
like that the prophetam and it's
difficult it's difficult to follow this
nowadays I agree 100 I I don't follow
this perfectly but
um the process he would only joke in
ways that were truthful right he
wouldn't even tell a lie in a joke so in
in saying things even jokingly you know
imagine saying something uh negative
about Allah as a joke it's not a joke
that's that's a messed up soccer a lot
imagine saying something negative about
the dean as a joke it's not a joke so
same thing especially when you're just
typing it we don't we can't read the
irony in it right we can't read the
sarcasm in it it just it everyone took
it seriously all three panelists and
people in the comments and they lost
their mind as you saw don't say that
even as a joke
Donny boy Donny get your racism in check
boy
uh come on now I think I think people
you know out trying to expose Khadijah
but oh my God you just exposed yourself
subhanallah but we will wrap this up
soon
um we got one from uh let's see
brother Sharif
YouTube member and the super chat about
us Muslims and RP differences bro we
made video on we made a whole video on
that bro we don't want to waste time now
yeah type in the three Muslims and then
like
you want to quickly give any books you
have on Islamic philosophy just because
we want to Blaster the last amount of
questions class
you can even give up I'm not I'm not
even the this bro I'm not the best
person to give recommendations on this
colors
um I would say yeah
Mommy if you have any
um read start start with um Imam I think
that's his name his book on tawheed
start with that insha Allah
okay next question we got from Brother
I think it says Sally I want to drop out
and start an online business
praise the Carter
that's it don't don't listen to what
anyone says praise Takara if Allah gives
you the guidance to drop out and start
an online business then you know you
can't go wrong with it but if you play
this Takata and you see direct sign from
Allah to not drop out then it would be
very unwise of you to drop out at that
point yeah my this the steps to is first
you reflect on it yourself and then you
do something called I think it's the
shadow which you go and seek you know
people's advice and stuff and then when
you when you make a decision yourself or
even if you're still confused you phrase
tahara what I will say this is contrary
to what brother Angel said to just use
your discretion right do what you think
is best insha Allah and praise the
father make Dua for sure
I would say don't drop out of school
because you if you have both yes it'll
be harder to scale your business because
you have less time and resources
allocated to your business
but that is genuinely the safest option
if you if you start your business and
you notice at some point it's not
getting anywhere and it's just not
something that is sustainable or
feasible you're still in school you
still have that at least as a cushion
but if you start it and you see that
it's going somewhere and then it's
gotten you to a good place where you're
comfortable dropping out of school and
continuing with it and you see long-term
sustainability in this business then you
can drop out praise the hot obviously
but then it would be safer too I'll just
you know reckon discretion and uh
caution inshallah no but you said it
perfectly I would have said that I just
wanted like to give a very simple answer
so I just said praise the father yeah
sorry I forgot we're ending I keep going
on tangents yeah no you're good bro
you're good
okay next
super HMI right is it true that doing
seed retention for too long will give
you prostate cancer again we can't give
medical advice we're not qualified but
not releasing frequently uh in a
permissible way obviously islamically
too as a man will lead to prostate
problems on average so we recommend that
you get married
let me jump in here at the same time
what about like um nocturnal
let me
let me jump in on this boys
so you have
what you just said the nocturnal
emissions
that is your body releasing so will you
have issues because you're retaining no
now they did a study on this where they
had groups of young men and then groups
of older men the young men were like I
think it was like 15 to 30 and the older
men were like 50 and up right and for
the younger men
if they released too often it actually
caused them to have more of a risk to
have prostate cancer than if they didn't
release as often but for the men over 50
not releasing as often actually
increased the risk of prostate cancer so
where whereas the young it's reverse the
older it's it's completely opposite so
what you hear from doctors saying oh
like you have to release or else you're
going to have prostate cancer that's for
older men
not for the younger men for the younger
men it's actually learning how to
control yourself and and not releasing
so damn much
thank you uh nofap Guru
no that was actually that was that was a
great element
of 32 bro I love about it
um uh brother writes assalamu alaikum
how do you Brothers avoid women that try
to tempt you into Xena
women don't try and tap me into I don't
know who you think we are or at least me
I don't have women coming up and we're
like hey yo come here I'm not used to
fall asleep
um but just lower your gaze don't talk
to them if they try you know get out of
my face leave if you just if you push a
woman away enough she'll you know her
ego will be triggered and you'll be like
you know screw that guy he must be some
women bro they try harder trust me bro
this is not
yeah no you you got to do what Ali dawa
did remember when you had Ali dawa and
he said he was uh talking to the one
sister and he wanted to like get to know
her for marriage but then she was like
she was basically trying to grow like
the Xena room and then he was like
sister like he basically just told her
the truth like look like I'm trying to
do this like proper you'll be trying to
do this I think you should you know get
this you know get this fix in your head
because this is not the way to do it and
then she came back to him she came back
to him months later
basically saying thank you
so it's like in this situation but if
you have a girl that's trying to like do
something like bro television like I'm
trying to get to know you with the
intention of marriage so let me get your
Wally's number and if she still doesn't
want to do it then be like okay well we
can't talk
you know it's as simple as that you have
to be probably with it you have to have
your boundaries you have to stand for
that because if you don't stand for that
then you're just gonna fall for it you
know that's money that's money
the next question we got and for the
super sticker um what is the best way to
support our local massage which needs
funds to be built via YouTube
um from what I know I know you can you
can you know give some insight on that
because you got a friend that does
fundraising right
um we all got a brother mashallah uh
shout out to you if you're watching this
but this person does recommend running
ads and campaigns
um but again we're not experts in this
so we can't speak on that we set out a
specific portion of every dollar that we
earn from YouTube and everything that
you guys donate for a Masjid fund
alhamdulillah we have enough money to
build a Masjid bro already so uh
inshallah that's gonna come soon
inshallah whenever moving time Vlogs and
everything will be up but that's kind of
what we're doing we're doing the organic
route I think if you guys are in a time
crunch to build the YouTube following
and raise money isn't necessarily going
to be the fastest way unless you can go
viral or something like that but you can
do a GoFundMe and yeah
then if you if you really like in your
time comes like that or if you just want
it to be a better way to provide for the
Masjid
reach out to like the Muslim content
creators and like have a way to show
that what you are presenting is real
and that you're just looking to help the
Masjid because it really needs help like
I I went to a Masjid over here in France
where it's like the floor is just tarp
the floor is literally just taught and
all the brothers are praying on that so
it's like that would be a case where you
could show pictures you could show
videos and you can show the location and
everything and they could even come out
to see it if they want you could give
them the opportunity for them to come
out and see it so that way they know
it's real and then you ask them to
help out and I mean come on now like
if they if the Muslim which
I'm not trying to like
try anyone here but like they're gonna
help you know like this is what we do we
help our brothers and sisters hmm
okay blue ass what is the best career
for Muslim women I would say bro become
a mother or says what about you too
I'm not a career it's just something
creative a creative outfit don't look at
it as a career careers from them careers
for men because career is something that
you have to like be literally giving up
your free time and time with your family
to be able to do so that you can provide
that's what a career is but if you do
something as a creative Outlet you can
make money from it or you can not make
money from from it but it's still a
creative Outlet so you're gonna do it
either way and you're gonna enjoy it you
know what I'm saying so it's like that's
what a woman should be doing and a woman
does that best when she has a proper man
that can support her that can provide
for her women that you see who are
providing for themselves they they don't
have the opportunity really to have this
creative value and if they do have the
creative value it's not as proper as
when they they have that space
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah 100
mom you're going do what you know what
you're good at what's Halal what you'll
be helpful beneficial in right and that
could be you know what brother Angel is
saying with a with a hobby or a queer
not something that's not monetary but
it's beneficial right you could be a
teacher for example you can go volunteer
at an Islamic school and teach a Sunday
class or go to the Masjid start a Sunday
class if you have the knowledge to do it
you know you can go based off a book
that you understand and maybe teach some
some younger sisters or maybe children
there are many things you could do do
what you're beneficial at right I think
it's very important that we have like
female dentists and female doctors
because you know when our wives or
sisters or mothers have to go to the
dentist or doctor I'd rather have a
woman working on her than a man so you
know these things are necessary forget
it if that's what you can do inshallah
go for it but be very careful prioritize
your family inshallah don't put off
having kids mashallah
next is you guys It's gotta be though
it's gotta be though like something that
Allah Wills you to you know yeah um it
can't be for the money and this is like
before I even get to this like this is
what I want to say it's very important
to like make the distinction here
because for men we could we should all
have like a creative value we should all
be like trying to do something that we
actually enjoy that we actually want to
do in this world but like think about as
a man we could we could really enjoy
something and you could make a living
off of it but it's like you have to
think about those that you were
providing for like maybe your wife or
your family or something like it's not
just us we have the we have the not
priorities we have the
we have the the damn the burden of
providing right so because we have the
burden of providing we can't just always
think that oh I want to do this I want
to follow my patch no we have to think
like okay how can I make the best amount
for this so that I can provide and then
how can I make this amount as well so
that I have the free time to do these
things that I enjoy but for a woman it's
like again if the woman is provided for
it she's given the space to relax and be
in her feminine well then she doesn't
have to think this way she can just
think okay what do I actually want to do
what can I give my best you know how can
I do uh back then they would say like do
do God's work you know what I'm saying
all right so three more Super Shots uh
brother or sister always right on how
would you recommend marriage sites or
asking friends for getting married
options seem limited as a white Reaver
that never experienced racism but after
reverting I get rejected left right and
Center
yeah
um
look I'm gonna I'm gonna do
I'm gonna say what uh Ali dawa said
where it's like you just you kind of go
in whichever way that comes your way
but at the end of the day like Allah is
going to be the one that puts this
person in your life so
you don't know it might be it might be
through like a Halal marriage type site
and I'm not advocating for it I don't
like those things but it's like bro like
if
if that's what Allah is is putting in
your life then like it should be
blocking it if you didn't go you know
what I'm saying so the only way you know
is to actually go through with it and
just keep playing it harder so that
Allah keeps guiding me throughout the
entire way
Abdullah
next Super Chat Jose for supporting the
channel Brothers I have a close friend
once atheists debated him about the
universe contingency argument he went
agnostic after he has the Quran how can
I encourage him to look more into Islam
so like basically the next step
well a lot of the time it's not a
logical issue it's more of a emotional
one so maybe
he realized that logically there's
absolutely no way that he can be an
atheist because you can never prove God
does not exist and you definitely had a
role in that mail I'll bless you so he
said okay whatever I'm agnostic but for
him it's just pushing the problem back
one step now you can't go to him and ask
why are you atheist he can just plead
you know the fifth and confusion the
rest of his life if he really wants to
um obviously you know it will be held
accountable but in his head at least it
might be an emotional problem so
consider just being you know focused
have a focus on being a good friend to
him being a good brother being there for
him genuinely caring about him as a
Muslim should to begin with and
time to time when the time is right have
the discussion with him about Islam
listen I told you about the contingency
argument we Define what necessary
existence is that's exactly what we
believe in as Muslims now we have
established there must be something
necessary right so if the necessary
existence will for us a religion in a
way if God willed for us a religion in a
way there needs to be a way of
deciphering which religion is true if
any of them are true and then go into
arguments for Islam show the Prophecies
of the Prophet Muhammad peace upon him
uh if it is a logical thing but if it I
think it's emotional probably focus on
that end and make sure inshallah he's in
the right place to be able to listen to
your logical arguments and propositions
no I'm the law
brother who's there writes you guys
should do interviews with your Muslim
Subs on live streams inshallah we're
considering doing a call intro as Rami
mentioned a few streams ago
um so inshallah we will bring that back
uh bonjour writes how to buy properties
Halal away in GTA area
um it's tough man foreign investing
would be a little bit better now because
of the inflation here is crazy very
expensive to get stuff you want to get a
mortgage
um so I wouldn't even know what about
you guys
unless you met GTS Grand Theft Auto bro
then it's super easy bro I got you the
cheat codes too
um I the only thing I can think of is is
renting to buy but those options are
very limited I'm not saying this is
halal I don't know go ask a scholar but
I remember hearing about something
called life at Key which is like they
have like condos and stuff downtown
um where you can rent to buy so it's
like mortgage payments but no interest
and you you pay rent every month and
it's going towards actually fully buying
and owning that house eventually
um
yeah so
maybe you could go through something
like that and then you could also
and it's just ideas again like I'm not
I'm not one to give fat to us or
anything like that but this is just an
idea where it's like you get
um a mortgage or something like that
let's say it's Halal right you get a
mortgage you have money to pay back
right
but what you do is like when you buy it
then you just rent out the place I don't
know if you said that did you say that
bro is that what you referring to
wait what or no like when you buy the
place or no you he was saying you rent
the place and then part of your rent
goes towards building equity for you to
own the house whereas what I think you
are asserting is you buy it and then you
put it up for rent and then you you let
them kind of take over the mortgage
no kind of what I'm saying is like let's
say you got a mortgage just a lot of
mortgage you still have to pay this
money back
um but what you do now with the place
since it's it's kind of yours it's not
fully yours but tell me yours you can
rent it out like almost like an Airbnb
type deal and uh you could basically pay
for all of it within like a year if you
were really on it but guys it's not
Islamic advice yeah yeah again this is
just ideas I I don't I I don't know the
[ __ ] there was anything like that
seventh angel rights what do t3m think
about Andrew Tate any statements about
Islam we've already made a video last
week just watch that because we don't
want to take too long on this uh brother
Army writes salaam alaikum from across
the pond what do y'all think of new King
Charles III and it's previously shown
depth of understanding towards Islam uh
Rami made an excellent point bro Rami do
you want to talk about that about yeah
these non-muslims yeah I mean even if a
non-muslim understands Islam what does
that like why why should we care like
yeah that's good but the best thing they
can do for themselves is become Muslim
and if they don't even if they love
Islam but they don't become Muslim that
doesn't benefit us at all it doesn't
honestly I would say that it doesn't
even benefit him if anything it's
working against him because he knows so
much about Islam he loves it and he's
not practicing it there has to be a real
problem behind that so who cares
honestly who cares if he knows or loves
her even if he loves Islam who cares but
he's not a Muslim focus on us as Muslims
giving doubt to him to bring him to
Islam if you never accept Islam so what
who cares bro like it's not in our hands
it shouldn't we shouldn't take it so
seriously when Anonymous loves Islam or
why we give so much Authority and power
to these people who cares
it doesn't matter
okay last question for today sister
Charlie writes
do you guys do you think a guy can
change for a girl he is really serious
about or he really is seriously only if
he wants to only if he wants to change
inside
he he can't he can't change because of
the girl he has to change because he
wants to change
but don't don't do anything in terms of
marriage or or anything like that where
you basically expect something and you
hope someone to change because at the
end of the day that is out of your
control that's in the control of Allah
and a lot of themselves too so I would
just undo that by the way guys no more
Super chats because we we are going to
end the stream Rami do you have anything
to say to that
bro uh no let's just answer this one
last Super Chat yeah
um yes Brothers I told my friend about
prophecy that the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him it seems to be an emotional
argument I'm not sure how to counter
that just bro counter emotion with
emotion show them love show him what the
Muslim Community is like maybe something
will open up at his heart just know that
at the end of the day it's in the hand
of Allah you if even if he accepts Islam
you're not responsible maybe Allah used
you but it's not because of you it's
only because of Allah all right
see you guys once again made of this
voice match the like button we are doing
streams on Fridays at 6 p.m Eastern
Standard Time Fridays at 6 p.m which is
about 11 p.m in the UK and we are doing
it this time two Sundays at 12 p.m
Eastern Standard Time which is 5 p.m UK
time and you will get the in-person
podcast episode with all of us together
every single Wednesday inshallah from
now on
Insha'Allah
and with that being said